E aí
[Música]
Nós podemos ser felizes nesse mundo tão
desafiador eu fiz essa pergunta alguns
anos atrás e comecei uma jornada para
entender o que que é felicidade
sempre fui realista sempre tive um
propósito queria transformar o mundo
ajudar pessoas mas acabei adiando um
pouco esses planos para buscar me
sustentar para buscar uma vida que era
condicionada como sucesso para a
sociedade direito em uma grande
multinacional na área de marketing
comecei a crescer na carreira Tinha Um
bom salário tinha bônus tinha uma
relação estável tinha tudo o que era
sucesso para a sociedade
a e nesse momento comecei a me perguntar
para que essa vida de prazeres e
conquistas materiais era uma vida feliz
que eu tinha tudo o que era considerado
um sucesso pela sociedade por que que eu
achava ainda que faltava algo por que
que eu não me sentia tão feliz
E desde os filósofos gregos a felicidade
é a grande chave a grande busca do ser
humano
Aristóteles já dizia que a felicidade é
o sentido e o propósito da vida o único
objetivo e finalidade da existência
humana Ou seja quando a gente pensa em
casar quando a gente pensa em ter um
emprego quando a gente pensa em
conquistas materiais em status poder no
fundo a gente quer ser feliz
é mas a pergunta que vem é Será que é
possível ser feliz nesse mundo tão
desafiador
nunca se falou tanto na busca pelo
bem-estar pela saúde mental pela
felicidade
mas apesar dessa busca incessante de
alguma forma a nossa sociedade apresenta
os dados oposto a gente hoje é um mundo
doente ansioso deprimido frágil
solitário
e talvez a explicação para ser
felicidade é de que estamos buscando a
felicidade no lugar errado
não existe um grande mito na sua nossa
sociedade de que seremos felizes o dia
que a gente conquistar algo o dia que eu
casar você feliz o dia que eu fui
promovido Você é feliz o dia que eu
comprar um carro importado você feliz o
dia que eu tiver uma casa na praia você
feliz e na verdade a gente realmente
focou todos os esforços no menor tempo
possível para conquistar tudo isso a
gente acha que tem que casar até os 30
anos ter filhos até os 35 ser muito
bem-sucedido até os quarenta e se
aposentar milionário aos 60 anos e claro
que tudo isso com a barriga tanquinho
é mas quando a gente conquista tudo isso
de repente a gente percebe que não
existe uma felicidade duradoura
quando eu virei gerente de marketing de
fato eu tive um pico de felicidade me
senti mais feliz por alguns meses e
aquele momento realmente eu percebi que
aquele era o caminho então para
felicidade mas depois de meses ao
contrário ver um pico de infelicidade eu
me senti vazia me senti questionando
Será que agora que que falta para a
próxima promoção que que falta para
ganhar mais daqui para frente e essa
felicidade duradoura não existe por dois
motivos quando eu busco as conquistas
materiais o primeiro porque quando eu
conquisto algo Eu sempre vou querer mais
comprei uma casa de 50 metros agora eu
quero uma de 80 depois eu quero mais de
100 virei analista Sênior agora eu quero
ser gerente daqui a pouco eu quero seu
diretor então a gente fica numa busca
incessante como se realmente o próximo
passo fosse me trazer felicidade
Oi e o segundo ponto é que existe uma
comparação social
e a gente sempre vai ter alguém mais
bem-sucedido do que a gente ou mais
bonito ou com corpo melhor alguma casa
mais legal então quando a gente entra
nessas buscas por uma conquista material
a gente não vai ter uma felicidade
duradoura a gente vai ficar numa busca
incessante e é por isso que em algum
momento eu tinha essa vida que era
considerada de sucesso que que faltava
né aos 30 anos para eu conquistar Eu
sinto porque eu já tinha conquistado
muita coisa e mesmo assim eu senti um
vazio e uma falta do significado e eu
imagino que seja o que a gente hoje como
sociedade muitas vezes sente porque a
gente focou demais nesse mito da
Felicidade nessas circunstâncias
externas e falta algo e Aristóteles já
falava esse segundo Pilar para ter uma
vida feliz é sim é importante essa vida
Dori que é importante ter conquistas
materiais é importante ter uma vida de
prazeres mas a gente precisa também da
eudaimonia é uma vida de virtudes de
auto-realização uma vi o significado e é
por isso que eu larguei tudo que eu
tinha do Sucesso para de repente ir
atrás de uma vida com mais significado
em alguns pesquisadores durante décadas
foram tentar entender o que que traz
então Quais são os aspectos que
determinam a felicidade das pessoas será
que a genética a Doutora Sônia Gomes ke
junto com outra psicólogos e
pesquisadores Conseguiu chegar num
gráfico que é chamado de rapina Sky e
mostra três aspectos que determinam a
nossa felicidade o primeiro deles é sim
um set-point genético existe um ponto de
partida algumas pessoas nasceram' mais
sorridentes mais otimistas mais
resilientes mas positivas do que outras
Mas isso não é determinante existe um
segundo ponto que são circunstâncias
externas da nossa vida e como eu falei
Talvez seja o grande mito da felicidade
se minha casa tem 50 metros ou 100
metros se eu tenho o emprego dos sonhos
ou não se eu tenho o casamento dos
sonhos ou não isso determina a pouco da
nossa felicidade a verdade é que a gente
realmente acha que seu determinante mas
ele é pequeno é o terceiro aspecto e eu
acho que é melhor mensagem de hoje a
gente pode todos os dias acordar
escolher ser feliz
e eu comparo muito com um corpo saudável
algumas pessoas nasceram com corpo com
uma predisposição genética mais saudável
do que outras Mas elas acordarem todos
os dias escolherem ir para academia e
mudar a alimentação cuidado descanso ela
pode ter um corpo saudável Eu adoraria
fazer aula de pilates só uma vez por ano
e teu corpo humano saudável mas eu sei
que não é assim se eu quiser realmente
cuidar da minha saúde eu preciso todos
os dias me dedicar para isso e a
felicidade é exatamente a mesma coisa a
gente pode sim acordar escolher hábitos
e atitudes mais positivas para melhorar
nossa vida
Oi e para chegar nessas atividades Quais
são as atividades que eu posso trazer de
felicidade para minha vida o psicólogo
Martins L mann é um dos Pioneiros da
Psicologia positiva cria um modelo que é
chamado de modelo perma e são cinco
Pilares que mostra um pouco do caminho
para a gente ter essa vida mais feliz
é o primeiro deles são as emoções
positivas que a gente tem mais momentos
agradáveis do que desagradáveis na nossa
vida a vida não vai ser só de prazeres
só de coisas boas certamente ela vai
trazer problemas desafios burocracia é
uma parte chata mas se no meu final do
dia eu pensar tive mais emoções
positivas do que negativas eu tô no
caminho para ter uma vida feliz e os
estudos já comprovaram que ações como
meditar Como rir como encontrar os
amigos como namorar realmente afeta o
nosso cérebro melhora o nosso humor
melhora o nosso bem-estar
um pense Super Interessante é de médicos
que receberam chocolate antes das
consultas e simplesmente por parar em
cinco minutos e tem emoções positivas
para comer um chocolate eles fizeram
diagnósticos mais rápidos e mais
precisos
e a gente é uma sociedade que aprendeu a
não parar que a gente acha que
precisamos ser produtivos e a gente não
pode parar cinco minutos e eu queria
falar o contrário a gente para cinco
minutos encontra o que me faz bem eu
volto com mais atenção eu volto com mais
cognição com mais produtividade
Então encontre o que te traz emoções
positivas no seu dia a dia não existe
Fórmula Mágica e o Renata gosta às vezes
antes de uma aula de uma palestra para
meditar comer um chocolate lê um livro
viu alguma coisa no YouTube que te traz
emoções positivas
e o segundo Pilar é o engajamento que é
chamada de estado de flor que quando a
gente não percebe o tempo passar a gente
está tão engajado na atividade que a
gente nem percebe que eu tenho que
passou muito fácil perceber isso nos
atletas
às vezes também nos artistas mas a gente
acha que nós não temos estado de flor
somente Talvez os atletas e os artistas
e são mito porque todos nós podemos tem
engajamento o estado de flor na nossa
vida o que a gente precisa para saber o
que Thaís flor para a gente elas
conhecimento para entender o que eu amo
fazer e o que eu faço bem e quando eu
descubro Qual é a Quais são as paixões e
o que realmente é minha alta performance
é quando eu encontro o estado de flor eu
preciso de ações que me desafiem se elas
são muito fáceis elas se tornam a
partida vintage antes e se elas são
muito difíceis elas me trazem ansiedade
o estado do Flu é esse lugar do meio do
caminho do desafio que eu sou capaz de E
aí
é o que te traz flor pare de focar nas
suas fraquezas a gente olha demais para
aquilo que a gente não sabe fazer
diferente não gosta de fazer pessoas
introvertidas tentam ser mais
extrovertidas pessoas que não são
analíticas se esforça não fazem cursos
para serem mais analíticas e a gente
vive muitas vezes focando só no que a
gente não sabe só que nos seus dons só
que nas suas paixões só que nos seus
talentos é isso que vai te trazer flor e
obviamente felicidade
é o terceiro Pilar são as relações
positivas que é passar a vida com um
grupo de apoio
quando a gente é pequeno toda vez que a
gente cai toda vez que a gente chora a
gente sai correndo para abraçar alguém
que a gente se sente seguro Talvez seja
forma da gente se sentir seguro neste
mundo tão inseguro mas quando adultos a
gente acha que não pode parar de que a
gente não pode pedir ajuda então a gente
cai e acha que tem que levantar sozinho
e cada vez mais a nossa sociedade se
desconectou das relações Profundas
humanas e se conectar através de telas a
gente acorda pegando o celular ao invés
de abraçar a pessoa que está do nosso
lado
hoje a gente está jantando com alguém
focado em responder Stories e respondeu
WhatsApp ao invés de olhar para a pessoa
que está na nossa frente
mas a verdade é que seres humanos
precisam de seres humanos e precisam de
abraço precisão de toque e precisam de
uma conexão profunda
bebês prematuros crescem mais quando
eles são abraçados Por que que a gente
parou de abraçar porque a gente perdeu o
toque porque a gente parou de pedir
ajuda busca seu grupo de apoio
é o quarto Pilar é uma vida com
significado
e a verdade é que todo mundo precisa de
uma missão de um chamado de um porque
aqui normalmente a gente acha que tem
que ser algo muito grandioso que vai ser
o momento que eu abandonar tudo e tirar
meu sabático ou o ano que eu for meditar
na Índia ou quando eu abrir uma pousada
na Praia aí sim eu vou ter significado e
no meu dia a dia eu esqueço que eu posso
ter um propósito aqui agora mas a
verdade é que o significado tem muito
mais a ver com a jornada e com o dia a
dia do que com grande momento na nossa
vida
e a doutora M reais que diário conseguiu
enxergar que todas as pessoas
independente da profissão podem ter um
chamado e que inclusive existiam médicos
no hospital falando que eles trabalhavam
somente para pagar contas sem nenhum
propósito sem nenhum chamado enquanto as
faxineiras do hospital falavam que
trabalhavam para curar vidas e elas
falavam que conversavam com essas
pacientes que estavam mais tristes que
não tinham recebido visitas porque ela
se sentiam parte da cura dessas pessoas
então pare de achar que proposta aquele
grande momento na tua vida Busque o
propósito aqui agora as suas atividades
diárias na jornada que você tem agora o
propósito tem a ver com a nossa missão
mas ele faz parte do nosso dia a dia e
não desse Grande Momento
Oi e o quinto Pilar o último são as
realizações
Todo mundo precisa de metas Todo mundo
precisa de objetivos Todo mundo precisa
de conquistas existe um estudo de
pessoas que ganharam salário para fazer
nada parece o emprego dos sonhos eu
tenho certeza que aqui alguns gostaria
de ter isso mas na verdade não foi muito
pior do que eles imaginavam ele se
sentiram sem propósito sem realização
sem produtividade e se tornaram muito
Infelizes Para sermos feliz a gente
precisa se realizar a gente precisa ter
uma meta a gente precisa ter um objetivo
mas a gente precisa também que Celebrar
no meio do caminho não espere Trinta e
Um de Dezembro para Celebrar as suas
metas veja as suas conquistas da semana
de hoje de ontem a gente precisa assim
se sentir realizada outra ser feliz e eu
falo que a gente precisa desse cinco
Pilares nenhum pode ser nota zero nenhum
se a ser nota 10 mas certamente a gente
só dão equilíbrio entre todos eles não
dá para ter uma vida de Emoções
positivas em significado não dá para ter
uma vida de engajamento sem ter relações
positivas então entenda como é que você
tá nesses cinco Pilares Porque de fato
felicidade é simples tem a ver com o dia
a dia tem a ver com a tua jornada tem a
ver com relações positivas com emoções
positivas tem a ver com o momento de
engajamento que a gente enxerga no dia a
dia tem a ver com ter algo para sonhar
tem a ver como fazer os atos de bondade
no nosso dia a dia o sentirmos ajudando
o mundo deixando algo para outras
pessoas fazer Impacto positivo em outras
pessoas não espere o novo normal não
espere o mundo perfeito não existe
Vivemos em um mundo frágil e o mundo
ansioso em um mundo deprimido e Nós
seres humanos também temos nossos
desafios e nós temos uma mente divagante
nós temos um viés negativo nós temos
medos nós temos ansiedade Mas a gente
pode saber que talvez dependendo das
minhas escolhas dependendo dos hábitos
dependendo das atitudes eu posso sim ter
essa vida mais positiva eu posso ter uma
vida com mais bem-estar emocional
bem-estar físico bem-estar espiritual e
boas relações Não espere a vida perfeita
construa o que de fato de trás emoções
positivas
engajamento significado e com certeza
uma vida mais plena e mais feliz
obrigada